Jim Nantz CBS sports broadcaster for the
NC double-a tournament the Masters NFL
and yes nominated for 2019 Sports heavy
outstanding sports personality
play-by-play in the category with Doc
Cameron type three nine eagle and Joe
Buck please say hello to the sea
what's up hey champ how you doing champ
good to see ya hello friends friends how
are you my bud great to see you great to
see you so Jim brought in his board so
when you do a game as the play-by-play
voice you have so he's got the games
from last week or do you have games for
what are these boards Aysen for
tomorrow's games also are made out the
matchups here and if you can show the
camera there let people know
are you comfortable doing that I guess
so small my little secret list here but
yeah this is the Auburn Virginia board
that will be in front of me during the
game now you're not reading from it you
know during commercials you might just
check it out to see what you're
forgetting and I'm still working
progress I'm about halfway through so we
read all week long here's Texas Tech and
Michigan State that's stories anecdotes
that you know you get to drop in the
broadcast if the time is right how long
does it take to do those who work all
week long on it honestly I I finished
the game in Washington the Michigan
State Duke game I flew to California
that night and and worked all the way
back West on just a preliminary set up
and then you just read Dropbox and scan
and read and read all I haven't seen
that before that's interesting I might
want to just write that one down under
this players a little specialty box and
it has not done the same process for all
these years and this is my 29th final
four play-by-play 34th overall so this
will be my eighty fifth sixth and 87th
fine
for games the broadcast which I just was
thinking about that while ago talking to
you
87 games that are big you know they're
all important yeah you know high stakes
intense and it's a lot of my life's gone
by right here at this event it's been a
great honor difference in doing
basketball play by play and football
play by play well I have a three-man
booth here with the great Grant Hill and
the remarkable Bill Raftery I love those
two guys and we're stray seas on the
sidelines and basketballs moving at such
a fast pace that your storytelling is
really condensed you have to be super
succinct there is no long form
storytelling here at all
and as I say when I do football and I've
said this to you before a good show for
me is if my analysts have a good game
you were talking about the Emmy
nominations it's always an honor but the
greatest honor for me is to see when my
analysts get nominated and I have both
Bill Raftery and Tony Romo make the
final five there and top five analysts
that was a win for me so no matter what
happens I'm just thrilled that that
they're getting the recognition they
deserve who told Tony you got nominated
for an Emmy you know I don't know Tony
was playing golf last week down at the
dominican republic we did not speak this
week we're pretty much in contact all
the time but if I'm in the middle of
March Madness and yeah I think I was
kind of latent in the game to find out
as well I was in transit in fact in
Minneapolis when I guess all the the
nominations came out and and I didn't
know about it for several hours after so
after that and I forgot not actually
just completely forgotten that or even
that was we're in that season where all
that kind of gets revealed I same way
because McLovin we're at the airport
flying here to Minneapolis and he goes
oh oh and I'm like congratulations you
thank you yes the show got nominee
unlike some of us who are nominated go
and I'm thinking oh boy that can't be
good and I just say this because it's
whatever it is it's 8:25 back on
California Pebble Beach and my little
ones are up right now yeah so
and Jamison wherever whatever camera I'm
on you're watching your daddy can't wait
to see you later today oh well that's
nice and your wife of course and
Courtney's got him huddled by the mall
you're the art concerned about the dent
in the side of my house okay that was
the worst golf shot of all time
it really a ricochets off my garage door
after hitting Finley's bedroom window
and then boom it's somehow like bounces
around three times like a trickshot you
couldn't replicate it in Atlanta on a
green about four feet away and he wins
the closest to the whole contest trophy
still looks the same and richly deserved
but but i have to i think van de Velde
shot might have been worse than McLovin
but that's it that's probably the only
one that's worse so it's that one will
go down in the annals is one of the
greatest moments in the history of the
game when you took the title you could
even get it airborne a couple you
whipped one time I did you gave you made
the mistake he gave me a lesson that I
took you down yet I've had you a lot
more pressin but I've learned my lesson
and I did not tweet any photos out this
year what was the lesson don't tweet
photos of the tournament that is
whatever happens in the par-3 tournament
stays in place last year you means
talking about when you revealed mine
when you screwed up yeah when you
screwed up McLovin yeah your wife was
not happy to meet me all's forgiven it
was a little uncomfortable though it was
just a little awkward there yeah and I
said I said you know just you might want
to apologize you know but tread lightly
there he's in good standing can we get
Jim some water please
all right oh thank you yeah or burger
guys got to go out for it we don't have
any no I thought you guys gonna be
outside and thank you very much with a
huge throng you know no Mike Mike last
year San Antonio San Antonio mr. Park I
like this beautiful
winch line I just like the jump shot by
the way I don't know if your there was
much jump in the shot but I mean he did
make was I higher than Mickelson making
the putt in 2004 at Augusta no more I'm
gonna go with Mickelson there
yeah did you play basketball in high
school of course I did it's captain on
my team were you any good
we went my junior year we were 120 - I'm
not embellishing at all my senior senior
year we bounce back and again I served
as co-captain that year we were 2 and 20
okay so my varsity career record at
Marlborough High School in Marlborough
New Jersey was 2 and 42 and somehow that
propelled me to calling 29 final force
and I'm in Springfield by you know some
weird twist of fate I'm in the Hall of
Fame there so in the broadcasters window
- and 42 how good a golfer were you at
your best and my best I could shoot bar
okay now I'm back when I we were kids we
didn't really talk about handicaps or
anything like that but I played a lot of
serious junior golf and amateur golf am
i growing up years down at the Jersey
Shore and I just wasn't committed to the
game 12 months a year and I think the
coach at the University used to took me
on potential and threw me in a dorm room
with his three most decorated freshman
recruits because I think he saw a
serious goal minded individual who could
maybe be a good influence to make sure
they got out of the dorm room in the
mornings when with the class but uh you
know I I was on the fringes I lettered
for a year on the golf team but I was
definitely outclassed I was I I couldn't
compete at the University of Houston if
I said you could have your career or
phil Mickelson's career I had the
greatest job in the world and I say that
it would total gratitude in my heart I
still can't believe you wouldn't trade I
wouldn't trade anything for this
I really wouldn't I mean this is exactly
what I wanted to do when I was like 11
years old and I never have had any sense
of entitlement I'm supposed to be
calling the Final Four it's on the birth
certificate
I'm supposed to go to Augusta next week
whatever I've worked hard for it but
I've always been grateful for the
opportunity I wouldn't trade it for
anyone you know how many people come up
to me Dan and say you have the greatest
job in the world
you know it's debatable it depends on
what it is it makes you happy and and
what's you how do you measure success
and but I just feel like for me to be
able to have a childhood dream this is
exactly what I wanted to do I wanted to
work for CBS when I was a little boy
because CBS broadcast the Masters and I
loved the way CBS presented the NFL they
didn't have the NCAA Tournament I was
growing up yeah it was on NBC but I
count my blessings every day I truly do
if you could pick what your last event
would be the Masters yes Final Four or
Super Bowl you hit it right off the top
I hate to be talking like that's
imminent
I certainly hope it's not but because
I'd like to do this for another 15 to 20
years and but if there was one place
where I would want to say goodbye and
step aside from the business it would be
at Augusta last time you got overcome
with emotion I'm I'm a pretty good crier
I get pretty emotional about things I
think I get knocked for that a lot
people think I get syrupy or sentimental
but it's just it's in my DNA and you
know it's just the way just the way I
was raised I get that from my mother
my mother is very touched by things and
I am too and are certain stories I'm not
choked up and just losing my soul okay
there are certain stories that just
unfold before you but what people can't
see you because you're not on camera but
I'm moved by it I'm moved by an
achievement something that represents
excellence and you know the effort
that's been there and the passion and
all the years our hard work to get there
and it just downright moves me like one
you know it could be a player winning a
golf tournament it could be you know who
knows maybe it's Monday night I will
tell you this that Monday night when the
the broadcast comes to an end that they
played that one shining moment I know
it's become cliche for people I happen
to love the song do you don't Bruce
Pearl last year when his daughter got
married the daddy-daughter dance at
their wedding was one shining moment how
about that I didn't know yeah now they
could be playing that song for him on
Monday night you never know and he's a
mess too now he is he's a great
storyteller he can't
for I had breakfast with him this
morning 8 o'clock he got choked up I
made him cry yesterday huh well I said
you do that to people that you know
you're known I said look back at that
Stadium there you're gonna be coaching I
guarantee you got touched by that but
Monday night I have a tradition with my
oldest daughter Caroline we stand on the
floor they play one shining moment out
to the world on the feed and it's pumped
into the arena and we stand there with
our arms around our shoulders and it's
just some very move by that to have that
with my child
it means excuse me it means a lot to
both of us and you're letting go of a of
a celebration of the game that has
really enraptured America for the last
three weeks and you see all these images
flash by and it's been a blur for me
I've just done 12 games in the last like
16 days or something that's why I have
no voice it's always hanging by a thread
when I get to the final four and I go to
Augusta and sometimes I need a little
booster shot I really do because I have
no voice left by the time I get to
Augusta but wait a minute wait this
could be performance hand it would be I
will check with the Sports Emmy people
Wow
you're back in then it just happens
every year for me it's a it's a
tradition of my together but it it's
your letting go of it and it's a passage
of time and I get to have you know my
daughter there with me arm and arm and I
walk off the floor and I have to
immediately kind of transition my
mindset to what's coming up in the next
six days so it's a nice goodbye and it's
something I get to share with her
talking to Jim Nantz the CBS sports
broadcaster broadcasting the NCAA
tournament the Masters and of course the
NFL and you make that transition you go
from something where there is excitement
you're able to yell or be loud yeah and
then you go to Augusta and is that hard
at all to use your voice in one way and
then all of a sudden you know it's not
hard at all I think I think a lot of
people that don't understand golf think
that that's you're trying to suddenly
like trick up your voice at the golf
tournament
to try to create some sort of false
drama synthetic drama the reality is it
would be really awkward if I went to
Augusta and sounded like the guy that
was calling the Monday night
championship game yeah Tiger wouldn't be
authentic that would be false that that
that would be really delivering a lie
with just a pitch of your voice
naturally you acclimate to the
surroundings that you have in Augusta or
any golf tournament for that matter you
don't yell you don't pitch your voice
you don't force your voice during action
it's just it's a quieter sport it's more
at a conversational level it's whereas
your pitch it's like we're talking right
here yeah this is my voice that I would
use on golf I would talk at this level
right here but if we were inside this
stadium behind us there were 70,000
people to talk above and through that to
cut through Dan you have to pitch your
voice to a certain level you have to
really drive it to cut through the din
of all that noise is it
it's just what comes naturally do you
like the sound you of your voice uh the
proudest thing I can say about my voice
is that it's my dad's voice my late
father's voice was identical to this I
have his voice he gifted it to me now
he never used his voice professionally
he was never once interviewed or had a
microphone in front of him or anything
like that but he bequeathed me his voice
he gave it to me and you know if you
picked up the phone years ago you really
people couldn't tell which one of us was
answering the phone I think we're pretty
close to being sounding identical and I
know you know this and but your kids
have this archival footage of dad I mean
there that's always your voice will
always be there never thought of it that
way I until you just said it that way
you know all those all those clips you
know they'll fill out they'll outlive me
because I've been again given the great
gift of being at some of these
significant events just dumb luck I
happen to be there when Tiger won the
night
1897 masters and he he closed it out
with a four-foot putt at the 18th to to
win by a dozen shots and and and I and I
said there it is a win for the ages well
that little narrative over that who will
be played back a hundred years from now
when somebody builds the opening montage
and tees for the Masters that's a moment
that's that's it's evergreen
transcendent moment that will go on in
time I didn't really think about it at
that time whatever it might be a Super
Bowl finish or a Gordon Hayward nearly
making the shot the half-court heap at
the end of the game those clips are
gonna be played back for a long time
you just hope you do them right but do
you think that you truly captured like
is there a moment you talk about tiger
is that the one that you go got it
like I captured the moment in the way
that it needed to be captured no regrets
you always have a little bit of doubt in
the back of your head because it's live
and you're not sure if you did it right
in you go back and listen to a show and
it's especially if it's like the next
day it never sounds like anything of it
any part of it was was that great not
that it ever is great but you got that
one though the tiger well can I tell you
a brief story I know he probably up
against the clock here but I felt some
pressure of the night before because
that moment was on the way
and Tiger led by 9 going into Sunday and
he was gonna become the youngest
champion he was gonna set the 72-hole
scoring record he was gonna have the
largest margin of victory and then of
course the social significance of Tiger
coming to Augusta and winning I mean
this was a gigantic moment and I gave a
lot of thought and some people said oh
you've you pre-planned that why you
scripted that I know you didn't just
come up with that but you know there's
certain situations where you know what's
gonna happen if I didn't think it
through the night before I wasn't doing
my job for example if I was a writer and
I was covering the 1997 masters and on
Saturday night with Tiger leading by
nine if you weren't thinking of how you
were gonna write your lead the next day
and instead you decide to go out and
have dinner and
you know three or four beers and a
bottle of wine you're not doing your job
somebody should take your press pass
away the people that are paying your
expenses your job is to go down there
and document what's gonna happen I knew
I was sitting on the precipice of
history and I felt figuratively
I felt the presence over my shoulder of
Jim McKay Jack Whittaker Pat Summerall
they were all still alive and I knew
that at that time I knew they would be
watching the next day and I knew they
would want to see how that moment was
handled so I knew it had to be succinct
I didn't know it was gonna be a
three-foot putt but you knew he was
gonna win and I've I just thought of
what could last in time was something as
important as his victory and ultimately
I thought to describe it as a win for
the ages would be the appropriate line
for that moment it was a you captured it
you think it was the right one I didn't
know it's told so you just validated it
I'm serious I mean I've never really
talked about it but I hear it all the
time it plays back on all the promos and
openings and things like that I'm I'm
pretty proud of it it was a prideful day
for all of us as CBS because there was
no drama in terms of who was gonna win
and the storytelling that came out of
our entire crew both verbally and and
and and through the through the lens of
our cameras the way that was shown it
was fresh every step of the way there
was nothing that was repeat it was all
great storytelling documenting a
historical moment that's one of the
biggest of our time in any sport and
anything it was Tigers first major
championship I did something nice for
you be nice if you did said some nice
about us can I just say this because I
know we're gonna be good bye I really do
think an awful lot of you guys I love
you guys and I feel I do feel a kinship
with this crew I'm glad weather is
happened you know over the last couple
years when you've been in my home yeah
it's been special I hope we'll continue
it you're always invited back even
McLovin he's got to come back as the
defending champ you you are on your and
100% good now yeah bye you didn't count
my win in those those great moments you
know did I have a call but you had the
garage you beat me in the five you
shocking damn went out in the first
round I know I'd been drinking before I
got to your house yeah it was obvious
yes I had the calling I had a couple of
bottles of the calling there he's Jim
Nantz he'll be on the call tomorrow
night and of course Monday night and
then heads to the Masters for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]